so now that you've set your two
marketing goals to work off of let's
explore this a little bit more now make
sure you're thinking about what you hope
to actually achieve and what outcomes
you're really looking for you need to
think about different objectives for
different stages in your product
lifecycle is your goal now branding or
drive traffic increase app downloads
improve engagement is it a call to
action we don't have to be too visionary
here these are not our startups
high-level goals and we're not going to
change the world with our marketing
goals we want you to set goals that are
down to earth and attainable
so think short term goals like within
the next few months that way you can
break them into smaller pieces and can
track them easily also be authentic pick
a goal you actually care about will be
meaningful to your business this will
help you to stick to it and achieve it
to be able to track your goals they have
to be measurable and aligned with your
performance